moments before the chauvin trial verdict
came down yesterday police in columbus
saved the life of a black girl who was
about to be stabbed
now don't take my word for it or law
enforcement's body cam footage shows us
exactly what happened but instead of
giving you the truth the media they're
just echoing the vicious lies of radical
leftists and racial demagogues
and they're using this tragic incident
again to further smear police officers
as unrepentant vile racists among them
is former obama flunky valerie jarrett
who framed the columbus incident like
this saying a black teenage girl named
makia bryant was killed because a police
officer immediately decided
to shoot her multiple times in order to
break up a knife fight demand
accountability fight for justice
now let's get something straight it's
not a knife fight
but only one person is armed and doing
the attacking that's called a stabbing
and watching the body cam footage
released yesterday i mean
it looks like makia bryant was about to
stab another girl who happened to be
black
so does jared and all the other people
who chimed in today
and last night do they really think that
cop should have just stood by
and let that poor girl possibly get
stabbed to death do nothing
is that what the social justice system
would look like
if the left really got in charge
according to radical activist brie
newsome that's exactly right she tweeted
this saying
teenagers have been having fights
including fights involving knives for
eons
we do not need police to address these
situations by showing up to the scene
and using a weapon against one of the
teenagers
you all need help i mean that sincerely
that is just deranged but not to the
media
the kia bryant a 16 year old girl in
columbus ohio
called the police for help an officer
was on the scene
and in 22 seconds he shot her dead what
if it were a member of your family your
neighbor are in a uh
essentially a teenage fight a schoolyard
fight
so many other black people will face
similar fates
the police will not exercise discretion
will not
use a reduced sense of engagement
to preserve black life now just as
pathological
was attorney ben crump's tweet from the
night before columbus felt the sting of
another police shooting as columbus
police killed
an unarmed fifteen-year-old black girl
named makia bryant
another child lost of course it's just a
complete lie but one that was
uncritically echoed
by the new york slimes they only
corrected the egregious falsehood
after getting caught but by then the
white house had already committed to the
media
of its own version of the big lie
the killing of sixteen-year-old michaela
bryant by the columbus police is tragic
she was a child we know that police
violence just proportionally impacts
black and latino people in communities
and that black women and girls like
black men and boys
experience higher rates of police
violence our focus is
on working to address systemic racism
and implicit implicit bias head-on and
of course to
passing laws and legislation that will
put much-needed reforms
into place at police departments around
the country oh my god she's awful
the only implicit bias i'm seeing right
now is against blue lives
because what we just laid out for you
was the anatomy
of a dangerous soviet-like smear
campaign
that will only put americans and
especially black lives at risk
likewise the lies about the columbus
shooting are only fueling more division
more unrest more distrust and of course
more misguided marches
of course that was another lie that
wasn't there's just another lie they're
repeating more lies those stoking these
flames
they should just be ashamed they should
be called out remembered for all time